Translator: Andrea McDonough
Reviewer: Jessica Ruby
Well, I think that when I was in grade school,
I was still very much loyal to the way of thinking
that I heard around me,
so I couldn't imagine much further
than being either a lawyer or a psychologist.
And it's only a few years later
that I found enough freedom in myself
to really ask what drives me
and what I would like to do with my life.
And maybe only ten years later or more,
my path really started revealing itself
and these are the moments when I was brave enough
to really listen to what I want to do
with every waking moment.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.